so we have this story about uh the cdc
guidelines and the masks
and i guess the big news is that a mask
dispute prompts
heated exchange between rep swalwell and
marjorie taylor green aid
swalwell said the aide yelled at him
demanding he take his mask off
so quote i told the bully what i thought
of his order
all right first of all there was a
reporter there i think for the hill i'm
not sure
who said that marjorie taylor green's
staffer said
biden says you can take your mask off
that's what the reporter said
and then swallow got in his face said
don't you tell me what to effing do
and then he went on twitter and said
don't bully people who are wearing masks
or something
now we see this tweet from david hogg
did you see i don't know if you saw this
i have not david hogg said i feel the
need to continue wearing my mask outside
even though i'm fully vaccinated
because the inconvenience of having to
wear a mask is more than worth it
to have people not think i'm a
conservative i want to throw the masks
in the garbage
burn the masks i mean yeah it's done
isn't it i feel that way i mean didn't
biden just say yesterday that we could
we could take them off
right in certain you got your vaccine i
did have the vaccine are we gonna talk
about the
oh um ladies and gentlemen because we
are the bastion of real journalists
right we were uh we were talking before
the show with janice about these silly
videos where people have magnets and
they put them on their arms
and then i you suggested it you like
should we try it
i'm like if you want to put a magnet on
your arm so we're going to debunk
these ridiculous videos in real time
with janisteen who has a magnet
right and you're going to put it on your
heart yeah i i did have the
the pfizer vaccine i don't feel it
like it's just doing anything yanking
okay
i think that's where they put it right
yeah right on the arm
shoulder let's just just in case it was
this arm because i don't
well you got to let go oh it's gonna it
just it just
it's the people oh
and what should be surprising to
absolutely no one people's arms are not
magnetized by getting a vaccine
but how many people watch that video
yeah i think they went fairly viral
people believe
absolutely crazy stuff and it is it's a
bummer
you know we we have a lot of guests come
through here a lot of them are trump
supporters
a lot of them don't like the idea of
emergency
authorization or vaccine passports but a
lot of them got the vaccine and are like
look there's a difference between you
having a choice to go out and decide
what you want to do what's best for you
and then having the government say what
you have to do
or having now back back to the mask
topic
in new york city's uh new york state
cuomo is like we're not going to release
the masked mandate
it's control it's because he wants to
control it right
don't tell me what to do if you see some
of his press conferences and you tell
him
well you said don't tell me i said that
even though
he probably said that it's funny because
he's saying don't tell me tell me what
to do
while we're saying don't tell me what to
do it's the difference of
he's not saying don't tell me what to do
in a sense he's saying don't tell me
what to do with my kingdom
right well remember remember when the
vaccines first came out
he didn't want them right because they
were under trump right he basically said
no
no we we don't have any proof uh these
vaccines work
and so therefore i don't believe in them
this is the funniest thing about
uh the vaccine thing to me is that i i
find
most conservatives you know if you look
at like ben shapiro
their their main talking point is the
government shouldn't force people to do
it and vaccine passports are overreached
but you have a lot of people some of the
staunchest trump supporters who are very
much
anti-like vaccine i i don't think it's
necessarily necessarily
fair to say anti-vaxxer in the sense
that most of the criticism is with it's
a new
mrna is new it's emergency use and i
think it's fair for people to say out
you know
i'll talk to my doctor i'll decide
what's best for me but there's there's a
decent amount of people
who are supporting donald trump and
demanding he get credit for operation
warp speed
for getting the vaccine done and then
going like i'm not taking that crazy
thing are you nuts
right it's not everybody but it exists
all right and then you have people on
the left who are like the whole time
what was it i think kamala harris
cuomo were critical saying oh no you
know we don't have the research for this
we're not to do it
now that biden's president they're all
giving him a standing ovation
congratulations on the vaccine good sir
and they're not mentioning trump at all
of course not yeah it was even brought
up in a press conference
uh the other day where someone said to
cuomo well
the fact that you don't that people
don't want to get the vaccine
don't you attribute to that to in the
beginning you saying that you didn't
believe in the vaccine
oh i didn't say that some of these
people man
um i i gotta say credit where credit is
due
uh gretchen whitmer said the cdc said
we're lifting the mass mandates so we're
lifting the mass mandates
cuomo was like no he's he's he's
obstinate it's about tribe it's about
power it's about
i wonder if i mean he's the older
brother isn't he does he have an
older brother than you know no i don't
think so they have a sister
and they have chris the younger brother
yeah i'm wondering if like
he was looked over as a child so he's
desperate to assert his power to like
prove
something to somebody like why can't
these people be chill about it
now the cdc said do it you know whatever
all right fine i think he's always been
like that
uh i i really do think that he wanted to
be president someday
the fact that his dad never got to be
president i think he kind of took it
upon himself
to think that well since my dad never
got there i need to go there and for a
while people were calling him maybe
uh an alternative to biden did you see
the t-shirts that say homosexual on them
oh my god yeah people went a little over
one of those
[Laughter]
just one i can't like you make sure it's
a small
oh no he even wrote about it in that
stupid book
the leadership book he he wrote about
the cuomosexuals
i love how he's like he's the word in
the middle of course he did
physically painful i love how he's
writing a book about his success in the
pandemic while he's literally killing
people
i thought it was a joke when that report
came out that he was working
on a book a leadership book in the
middle of a pandemic
when thousands of elderly were dying in
nursing homes i thought it was like
the onion or one of those joke websites
yeah
but he was actually doing that you've
seen the babylon bee i'm sure
imagine how perfect that headline would
have been yeah governor
wright's book on his successes with the
pandemic while killing
worst governor ever yeah while killing
50 000 people well here's the thing
though
i think that book is going to be his
downfall
they could use that book in a court of
law there are so many lies in it wow
yeah i mean he lied about the nursing
home thing i mean the fact that they
covered up
the amount of deaths in the nursing
homes for so long
and how that was debunked by the new
york times that there is all sorts of
information
from his health department they were
going to release the numbers
for many months but it was it would we
were asking for the total number of
deaths
while he was writing that book while he
was trying to sell
that four million dollar book so the
fact that he went above and beyond his
health department and told them
not to release the accurate amount of
numbers
during that time does that confirm that
he told them not to yes
yeah it was it was covering it up he was
warned
by these nursing home experts if you do
this you will kill people
and he was like okay well i think we
have to find out the origins
of the march 25th order why was it
written
and not only him you mentioned whitmer
she had almost the identical mandate
and tom wolf as well uh and
new jersey murphy and gavin
uh gavin newsom yep maybe they just uh
all got together on a zoom call and
we're like let's kill people
well i would like to get to the bottom
of it i mean there are
several investigations right now there's
a federal investigation there's an fbi
investigation there's a doj
investigation which started under trump
i'm grateful to bill barr for starting
that because that's the that's the one
that got him all freaked out
when they found out that they the uh the
doj was
doing an investigation into nursing
homes and that's
when they realized oh my gosh they you
know they want accurate numbers
and that's when his top aide melissa
derosa
in a meeting with democratic lawmakers
closed door said
well we froze and we didn't want to you
know we didn't want to give the
information out because
you know that that would prove that that
maybe we had something to hide
they were wasn't it that they were they
knew it would result in an investigation
of course they were worried that trump
would use it to launch an investigation
so they obviously skated the numbers
and that's why she took a bunch of
democratic lawmakers into a closed-door
meeting to say
i'm really sorry we didn't tell you but
you know we couldn't we couldn't
you know put more fire in into this
situation because you know we didn't
want people to freak out
and and what they tried to spin it as
was they didn't want the trump
administration
to politicize these numbers that he's
blamed
everyone he has blamed uh god and mother
nature
and the trump administration at one
point he blamed the old people
because they're old and they're going to
die wow and think about the the the
context when he was like you know donald
trump would have used this
i mean he should have that the people
should have known what you were doing so
they can vote against it because i'm
sure they would have been upset about it
you know what what gets me though is
like why did the new york times go
against cuomo what happened
i mean they they were homosexual and
then all of a sudden they were like down
with cuomo
because it not just that not not just
this story all of a sudden all these
accusations started popping up against
them he's still
going i mean every time i think that
there's another you know
uh woman that's going to come forward
with harassment
you know actually every time there was a
new woman coming forward with some of
these sexual harassment allegations he
would start to lift
restrictions like okay you know what
restaurants you can have
75 of people to come in uh and you know
now
he's trying to open up new york again
yeah people have made
have mentioned that with joe biden as
well it's been a really bad week
inflation is freaking everybody out the
conflict of mid elite conflict in
in the middle east whitmer wants to shut
down a gas pipeline while another gas
pipeline was hacked and there's gas
shortages even right now
and then biden comes out you can take
your mask off just take them off yeah
hey everybody that changed the news
cycle real quick
now now the top story on like a bunch of
websites is like swalwell fighting with
uh with marjory taylor green i mean they
got us distracted a little bit
i gotta admit but but yeah so but but
why did the new york times
all of a sudden just come out and be
like no cuomo
the ag report uh new york's attorney
general leticia james who is a democrat
released a report in january that
basically did the
uh in investigation to what we've all
wanted which was the the accurate number
of deaths in nursing homes
he was go he wasn't counting those that
died in the hospital like my
mother-in-law for example she got
coveted in her assisted living residence
she died in the hospital but her number
did not count
he was the only governor that didn't
count those that died in the hospital
and you can imagine if you're not
counting those that's going to be a
significant percentage of
of numbers you're not admitting to so
latisha james did her own
document uh 76 pages that basically said
he was hiding the numbers and that's
when the dam began to crack
and that's when you started to realize
that maybe he does have enemies
in his own uh party well is leticia
progressive there are you know there are
thoughts that maybe she wants to run for
governor someday but i'll tell you this
much i don't care
what the reasoning is yeah i don't care
what brings them down either
you know people say to me well what if
it's you know the all these women coming
forward
doesn't matter to me as long as long as
something eventually brings him down
and the fact that there are
investigations into the nursing home
issue and more people know about it
you know i feel like i'm on the side of
the angels and hopefully
you know good will prevail you know it
would be great if ocasio-cortez wins the
governorship because cuomo gets knocked
out wouldn't that be
amazing i don't know who should run
through
his face amazing like a unicorn pooping
rainbows
like it's terrifying terrifying i mean
i'm sure there's a lot of people in the
country that would be
like governor c cortes oh kaiser cortez
would be amazing
i'm kidding um it would be amazing not
in the positive sense just like i'd be
amazing that would happen
awesome but man the democratic party is
just like knives out
do you think a republican has a shot at
being the governor of new york
i mean i want to say yes just because of
how awful everything's been
and if cuomo uh i'm assuming he can run
for re-election right i don't
yes fourth term yeah so is is there
gonna be any democrat powerful enough to
knock him out
and primary him or something i don't
know maybe
if if it's possible for a republican win
if it's possible for a republican to win
in new york i bet it's possible for
someone to primary cuomo
with new york city i'd imagine they
probably could get rid of him
you know they're all going to vote
against him but who could possibly
who could it be i guess is the question
who's got the charisma to
to actually run if they don't replace
cuomo because they don't have a strong
enough
candidate then i think a republican
could probably win because the rest of
new york state's going to be like just
enough already yeah i don't know what
that would mean though i mean that'd be
kind of crazy right when was the last
time new york had
pataki when was that gosh well that was
before him
right and cuomo's been in power for
three terms
so before that that was so not that long
ago yeah all right so then yeah i guess
so possible
it is possible well did you see what uh
who who tweeted this was it robert reich
or whatever his name is where he was
like
no maybe it wasn't somebody said that uh
2022
is the battle for the soul oh yeah it
was someone i didn't recognize
yeah some guy he was like it's the fight
to prove whether this country falls to
white supremacy or something yeah and
i'm like shut up you said that about
2020 and 2018 and 2016 every single
every two years but i have to wonder uh
the democrats have a very
thin grasp of power right now i mean the
house it's like 11 seats the senate is
literally no seats these have a
tiebreaker with kamala so
if what we're seeing now with the
ratings on these more progressive
uh outlets the ratings with cnn cnn and
msnbc going down
the democrats have gone back to sleep
the voter base is like
disinterested now that trump is gone the
conservatives
the anti-woke the anti-critical race
theory types
disrupted liberals they're active 100
so come 2022 i think we could see a big
push for the republicans to take control
of everything what do you think about
gavin newsom i think he's awful
yeah i do too but do you think that they
have enough
to get rid of them um man
what's the option caitlyn jenner
right now right yeah um who else was
gonna run
like randy quaid mentioned he was gonna
run or something i don't know i don't
know
well it's a runoff right or it's uh it's
a recall election which means
anyone can put their name in the in in
in the in the ring or whatever
and then they need a certain threshold
to win right
the problem right now is you know throw
it back like the mask stuff
tribalism very clearly controls
everything
so caitlyn jenner is taboo
you know all of these people who came
out and celebrated caitlyn jenner saying
you're brave we respect you you're
amazing and powerful
all of a sudden now are like you're evil
and wrong and we must resist it's
they're going to support gavin newsom
simply because of the tribe they're in
it's the democrats got to vote democrat
no matter what gotta wear a mask doesn't
matter what cdc says
so gavin newsom might win do you think
most people would take off their mask
yes i do i do because
you know what actually let me slow down
it's tough i think in the cities
people are man they they are
indoctrinated
i don't know if indoctrinate is the
right word but they are
very terrified terrified i mean it's a
better way to put it
but terrified of what exactly covered
yeah
still yeah sounds like it i mean you
look at that tweet from david hogg he's
like i don't want people to think i'm a
conservative so i'm gonna keep wearing a
mask it's like okay dude whatever
oh so that's not regular people are
gonna take their masks off it's freedom
yeah but even even out here so we're
we're
in the we're in the part of maryland
where it meets west virginia and
virginia
we have that we have the appalachian
trail over here i was riding my bike
down there and i saw people you're in
the middle of the woods
you're in the middle of the woods in
west virginia and there's like a guy
running wearing a mask
and i'm like i if you want to fine
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say
anything high altitude training
i guess it takes more energy to breathe
so you get stronger
if the logic of the mask was always you
don't want to spit on somebody
i'm like and you're in the middle of the
woods i if if he hit him
around his neck and he was running and
he saw me he pulled it up i'd be like i
got it thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you